the Snapdragon 8 Gen 3 is here and we
not only know the full specs but the
full performance in the first phone that
is coming in and let me tell you guys
Apple should be worried in this video
I'll give you guys a full breakdown and
how it Stacks up to the A7 Pro in the
iPhone 15 Pro phones which were just
released about a month ago and man is
this new chip impressive it has been
less than a year and qualcom has one
uped the 8 Gen 2 in phones like the s23
ultra and this phone has already beat
out the iPhone 15 Pros a17 Pro in 3D
Mark Wildlife extreme getting an average
of 21 FPS compared to 20.8 FPS using the
unlimited mode as far as Graphics
Qualcomm said that the H Gen 3 is 25%
faster than the Gen 2 which would mean
that it would get roughly 26.25 frames
per second which is very impressive in
this difficult ult 4K test Apple
advertised a 20% jump in graphics from
the a16 and they did achieve exactly
that in shorter tests but in our
20-minute stress test we only saw a 14%
difference since the titanium iPhone 15
Pros retain heat more so than the
stainless steel phones now even more
impressive the hn3 not only gets a
larger graphics performance increase but
it is also 25% more efficient I where
the A7 Pro is more power hungry than
before but the A7 Pro is 3 nanom so how
is this possible when the hn3 is a 4
nanm design well we made a whole video
on this but to simplify tsmc's 3
nanometer yields were so low that they
likely had to increase power to get
consistent stability on the lower
silicon loty chips because even Apple's
4 NM a16 was more efficient than the 3
nanomer with that Qualcomm has stuck to
4 NM but they have refined their design
even more getting better performance
lower heat and saving battery so it's a
win-win staying with 4 nanometer this
year now as far as the main CPU they
also got a 20% efficiency boost while
Apple for the first time in many years
has kept the battery life ratings the
same although we did see better Real
World battery life for performance
though Qualcomm stated a 30% performance
increase which is mindblowing year overy
year where Apple hasn't actually
achieved that level performance in many
years and the A7 Pro only managed a 10%
CPU boost compared to 30% dang and we
actually have a leaked Benchmark from
the xiaomi 14 showing an absolutely
insane performance score of
7,494 in the latest geekbench 6 which
blows my mind now the s23 ultra with the
Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 scored
5,284 in our test while the 15 Pro Max
got
7,272 so not only made up that big gap
but even exceeded the A7 Pro now we have
to take this with a grain of salt
because we don't know how this ship was
cooled and how it would perform in the
chassis of the s23 Ultra if we do the
math based off the s23 ultra we would
get roughly
6,900 or so which is still a massive
jump but we'll have to wait and see how
this ship performs in the upcoming s24
Ultra now there's a lot more that is
very impressive about this new chip but
first how did they achieve such a big
jump and caught up or maybe even beat
Apple's longstanding lead first off this
is an 8 core CPU compared to Apple's 6
core A7 Pro now Apple has always had
lower core counts for a very long time
and I remember when the iPhone 6s still
came with a dual core whereas my Samsung
had a quad core and Apple only moved to
quad core processors when Androids
started using aore Apple has always
focused on large high performance cores
and even the A7 pro has two main
performance cores and the other four
cores are just power efficiency cores
for saf saing battery life but Qualcomm
has done something different with this
year's CPU the hn2 had one high
performance core four mid-tier cores and
three efficiency cores so performance
was kind of spread around the hn3 still
has one high performance core running at
3.3 GHz but instead of four mid-range
cores at 2.8 they now have five cores
which run at a maximum of
3.15 so that is roughly a 13% speed
increase uh with a 25% boost in core
counts now they only have two efficiency
cores instead of three but they run
slightly faster at 2.27 instead of 2 GHz
what's going to be very interesting is
how will that affect standby time and
background tasks since Apple's four
efficiency cores are also very good at
performance and efficiency and that
really helps the battery life and the
standby time with that one of Apple's
biggest improvements is their neural
engine that actually had an impressive
Improvement this year but the 8 gen 3's
hexagon npu also got a very impressive
98% performance Improvement while being
40% more efficient one thing that I made
a big deal of is the new x70 modem
paired with the A7 Pro which made a
really big real world cellier speed
Improvement while also getting better
reception and saving battery life but
the Snapdragon 8 gen 3 gets an even
better one since Qualcomm is the one who
actually makes these for Apple 2 and the
new x75 now supports 10 GB per second
download speeds compared to 7.5 but real
world Improvement speeds can be better
than that
25% in fact Qualcomm is making really
big claims it is also 20% more power
efficient and of course Apple won't get
that for another year with the upcoming
iPhone 16 Series so they are about a
year behind now the iPhone 15 finally
got Wi-Fi 6E built in just like the
latest MacBooks but the Snapdragon 8 gen
3 has WiFi 7 support which has numerous
improvements even to help out 2.4 GHz
and the 5 gz bands whereas Wi-Fi 6E
mainly added the 6 GHz band and that
mainly just gives you better speeds if
you're in very close range the 15 lineup
finally got USB type-c which Androids
have been using forever and the 15 Pro
lineup has a port that is really
powerful beating out most androids for
example it could run at 10 GB per second
instead of 5 gbit per second and it has
full display port support so you could
connect it to a high resolution display
as well as powerful docks to get a ton
of different outputs and inputs well the
Snapdragon hn3 now has that as well
matching the 10 GB per second transfer
speeds and also really good external
monitor support just like the Flagship
iPhones it can also support 24 GB of RAM
which is crazy since the iPhone 15 Pros
have 8 GB but who knows if any
smartphones will actually support that
since it is really Overkill but the
memory speed has a 25% Improvement in
bandwidth at 64 versus 51.2 gbits a
second it also supports 4K 120 FPS video
which I suspect that the A7 Pro can also
do but Apple just isn't making use of it
even though the technically could with
the processors and same thing with akk
video which would be perfect with that
48 megapixel sensor but they are not
enabling it now one way that Qualcomm
still falls behind is single core
performance the a17 pro scores a crazy
high
2925 beating out the Snapdragon 8 gen
2's 2003 the new Snapdragon 8 gen 3
scores
2,27 so that is only a 10% Improvement
in single core performance compared to
the hn2 but that's all that Apple got
with the whole A7 chip performance Now
Android phones have pretty much always
had worse single core performance
compared to Apple's ship designs even
though Qualcomm tries to improve this by
having a single core that can clock
higher compared to the rest for example
the Peak Performance core in the
Snapdragon 8 gen 3 hits 3.3 GHz but
Apple's two performance cores hit a
crazy high 3.78 GHz that has a better
design so in single core the A7 Pro is
about 33% more powerful even though the
clock speed is just 14% higher so that
shows that Apple's design is just better
one thing that I've thought about is why
doesn't Apple just take the next step
and move towards an 8 Core Design right
now they are still sticking with the two
performance chords where where Qualcomm
now technically has six that are focused
on performance instead of efficiency
when you have more cores you can run
them at slower speeds which is a lot
more efficient than trying to get very
high clock speeds which is why having
two performance cores in the A7 Pro
actually uses up to 14 watts of power
compared to 10 watts in the previous a16
bionic and that chip is not that much
slower while using a lot less power so
they technically could run at a little
bit lower clock speed but have four
performance cores and get some insane
performance like they do with the new M2
and the upcoming M3 chips it is
definitely more worth doing that so you
guys let me know your thoughts down
below is it exciting to actually have
competition now on the Android side in
terms of processors hopefully that helps
Apple to really step it up with their
chip design and be able to um push that
further now that the competition has
caught up or maybe even exceeded them in
certain areas you guys let me know your
thoughts go ahead and click that Circle
above to subscribe check out one of
those videos right over there this has
been Max and I'll see you in the next
one
[Music]